problema 2 cuando una taza de té se
enfría la temperatura del té es modelada
por la ecuación diferencial h para hacer
un menor o igual que t menor o igual que
10 donde el tiempo está medido en
minutos y la temperatura hdt esta medida
en grados celsius algunos valores de hdt
y algunos valores del tiempo se muestran
en la tabla de a continuación en nuestra
tabla de aquí inciso a usa los datos de
la tabla para aproximar la velocidad a
la cual la temperatura del té está
cambiando en el tiempo te iguala 3.5
muestra el procedimiento que te llevó a
esta respuesta bueno lo primero que me
piden es que use los datos de la tabla
entonces creo que va a ser buena idea
graficar los datos que tengo en mi tabla
entonces voy a hacer que este es mi eje
de la hd de la temperatura y el otro eje
va a ser el eje del tiempo y dese cuenta
de que el tiempo es 0 2 5 9 y 10
entonces vamos a hacer esos intervalos
el tiempo es empieza en cero
por aquí está el 5 por hasta acá hasta
el 9 y aquí está el 10 y bueno la
temperatura está en 66 grados celsius
está por aquí y después en dos bajas 60
grados celsius entonces puede hacer por
aquí 60 grados celsius en 5 baja a 52
grados celsius está más o menos por más
o menos por aquí este va a ser mis 52
grados celsius en nueve minutos bajó a
44 grados celsius entonces bajó como por
acá aquí es 44 y por último en 10
minutos bajó a 43 grados celsius
entonces por aquí está cuando el tiempo
vale 10 minutos vamos a unir los puntos
para que nos dé una curva muy parecida a
esta muy bien y entonces vamos a hacer
otra vez el inciso a dice usa los datos
de la tabla para aproximar la velocidad
a la cual la temperatura del té está
cambiando en el tiempo te iguala 3.5
muestra el procedimiento que te lleva tu
respuesta y bueno que debe encontrar la
velocidad a la cual está cambiando mi
temperatura
el tiempo 3.5 es ni más ni menos que
encontrar la pendiente de la recta
tangente en la curva al tiempo 3.5
segundos ahora bien si yo tuviera la
función explícita sería muy fácil sacar
la pendiente de la recta tangente usando
la primera derivada pero como no tengo
la función explícita lo que voy a hacer
es usando los datos de la tabla
aproximar está pendiente con mis dos
valores más cercanos a 3.5 por lo tanto
la velocidad de cambio quién va a ser
pues va a ser el valor que esté evaluado
en 5 - el valor que esté evaluado en 2 /
pues la diferencia que hay entre 5 y 2
como esfera el promedio entre 5 menos
dos la distancia que hay entre los dos y
ya con esta aproximación solamente nos
resta sustituir y hacer cuentas entonces
vamos a hacerlo la velocidad de cambio
es igual a 85 pero h en cinco valía 52
entonces de 52 menos
2 que vale 60 ya esto dividirlo entre
cinco menos 2 que es 3 entonces esto es
entre 3 y bueno aquí ya está muy fácil
esto es lo mismo que 52 menos 60
- 8 grados celsius porque lo que estamos
midiendo arriba era la temperatura entre
3 minutos o lo que es lo mismo podemos
decir que en el tiempo 3.5 segundos la
velocidad de cambio es aproximadamente
menos 8 tercios de grados celsius /
minutos y bueno es toda la respuesta del
inciso y como todavía tenemos tiempo
vamos a trabajar el inciso b que dice
usando las unidades correctas explica el
significado de 1 entre 10 de la integral
definida de 0 a 10 de h de tdt en el
contexto del problema usa la suma
trapezoidal con sus 4 sub intervalos
indicados en la tabla para estimar el
valor de 1 sobre 10
el regal definida de 0 a 10 de h de tdt
bueno fíjense bien el área que tenemos
aquí abajo de esta curva esta área que
estoy dibujando aquí es la integral
definida de 0 a 10 de h de tdt y ya esta
integral hay que dividirla entre 10 es
decir la cantidad de unidades que hay de
0 a 10 entonces toda esta expresión que
tengo aquí es ni más ni menos que el
promedio de la temperatura el promedio
de la temperatura la cantidad de
temperatura total entre el tiempo total
es el promedio
temperatura y dice usar las unidades
correctas que unidades va a tener esta
expresión que tengo aquí bueno pues como
es temperatura va a ser en grados
celsius y de hecho se nota si nosotros
la analizamos con calma hdt estado en
grados celsius dt éste da dos minutos y
aquí lo dividimos entre diez minutos
entonces esto me queda minutos entre
minutos se va y me queda grados celsius
y ya está con esto tenemos la primera
parte de nuestro inciso b después dice
usa la suma trapezoidal de los cuatro
subirán los indicados en la tabla para
estimar el valor de 1 sobre 10 la
integral de 0 a 10 de h de tdt de la
íntegra que nosotros tenemos aquí y
bueno como no sabemos la función
explícita entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es dividir esta curva que tenemos aquí
en 4 sub intervalos para calcular el
área de cada uno de los trapecios de
estos intervalos de qué intervalo estoy
hablando bueno tengo cuatro sub
intervalos mi primero va a ser este y
este su intervalo a su vez da un
trapecio este trapecio que yo tengo aquí
su base es de 0 a 2
su altura es 66 en 0 y en 260 ahorita
vamos a ver qué hacemos con una altura
promedio después yo voy a agarrar a mi
segundo sub intervalo que es de 2 a 5
este de aquí decimos hacerlo con un
color más llamativo a este de aquí y por
lo tanto me da también un este trapecio
y ahora con el siguiente sub intervalo
que es de 5 a 9 también voy a obtener un
tercer trapecio entonces tengo aquí un
nuevo sub intervalo y tengo un nuevo
trapecio y por último me queda el sub
intervalo de 9 a 10 este de aquí y tengo
un trapecio muy pequeño y ahora lo que
voy a querer es estimar esta integral
con mis 4 trapecios sacando el área de
cada uno de mis cuatro trapecios por lo
tanto vamos a hacerlo como puedo
encontrar una estimación del área desde
trapecio pues bueno yo tengo que de base
tengo dos unidades de 0 a 2 hay dos
unidades y en cero el valor es de 66 y
en 2 el valor es 60 por lo tanto el
promedio entre 66 y 60 es 63
si yo multiplico la base por la altura
me va a dar un aproximado y 2 por 63 es
26 unidades ahora vamos con el segundo
trapecio qué pasa con el segundo
trapecio yo tengo que de base
tengo de 2 a 5 es decir la base este
trapecio es 3 de aquí acá hay 3 unidades
y voy a agarrar el promedio ahora de las
alturas en 260 en 5 según la tabla de 52
y 60 menos 52 es 8 por lo tanto el
promedio es cuatro
entonces me queda en 56
la distancia promedio entre 60 y 52 56
entonces voy a poner aquí 56 y ahora que
lo multiplique por tres me va a quedar
168 vamos con el tercer trapecio en
tercer trapecio tengo una base de 5 a 9
es decir cuatro unidades tengo cuatro
unidades en cinco vale 52 en 9 vall de
44 y de 44 52 otra vez hay 8 unidades
entonces 44 más 4 que es la mitad es de
8 me queda 48 48 por 4 x 48 y por 4 me
va a quedar 8 por 4 32 más 4 por 4 16
192 ahora vámonos con el último trapecio
el último trapecio tiene una base muy
pequeña de 9 10 y 11 unidad y las
distancias de 44 43 44 9 43 cm 10 su
promedio es 43.5 por lo tanto 1 x 43.5
pues es 43.5 no hay mucho que hacerle
entonces 43.5 y si sumamos el área de
cada uno
nuestros trapecios voy a tener una
aproximación o una evaluación de mi área
que hay abajo de la curva por lo tanto
vamos a hacerlo me queda 126 a esto hay
que sumarle 168 ya esto hay que sumarle
192 ya esto hay que sumarle 43.5 y esto
es 529 punto 5 529 punto 5 muy bien y
bueno este valor 529 punto 5 que acabo
de encontrar es mi aproximación de la
integral definida de 0 a 10 de h de tdt
ahora hay que dividirlo entre 10 acabo
de sacar este entre grado que yo tengo
aquí una aproximación que es 529 punto 5
y ahora lo que tengo que hacer es
multiplicarlo por un décimo o dicho de
otra manera dividirlo en tres días
porque luego yo lo que quiero es el
valor de la temperatura promedio
entonces vamos a hacerlo 529 entre
es igual al 52.95 6 bueno eso no lo
tenía que hacer con la calculadora pero
bueno ya lo tenemos aquí el valor de
estos 52.95 grados celsius y con esto
acabó el inciso b